okay hi everyone we are in the swing of
doing 13.3 design reviews we are talking
today we're first here today about pde
modeling and then we will be talking
about
a different topic what is the next topic
next topic is machine learning okay
machine learning
okay
all right should I look at this um at
this page here you could but it's that
that was more in FYI okay is it is it
done or is it still in development yes
it's it's done it's a final stretch of
getting released
okay maybe that's for a separate meeting
yeah
um yeah that wasn't yeah I hadn't
accounted for that in a half hour
okay
well when are we going to get to see it
I mean
um different meeting all right okay so
let's um
all right solid mechanics
so what should I be looking at here
so for Sonic which is not working oh
maybe it is oh yes it is so for silent
mechanics this version has it's the last
version that where we added the region
symmetry axis symmetric so we now can do
axis symmetric solid mechanics
simulations by the way I do think that
you know some kind of mesh element style
of automatic that isn't ugly primary
colors would be nice
okay
go ahead
um
yeah so that that's the feature for for
a solid the the new implementation
feature for solid mechanics
and then we've added application
examples why are these I don't
understand what the heck is this a
string what is this I don't understand
what this is so you're going into lower
level documentation this is not the top
this is in the the monograph of the API
the sort of programming API that's
underlying it
okay so what should I be looking at
the main thing that's had been added to
the modeling primitive is accessymmetric
those examples of which are kind of
showcases show how they come into play
the other thing that's added
is
uh you can see the second bullet and
third bullet these are
um
normally when you say axis metric does
that mean the coordinate system that
means you're only giving one coordinate
the radio coordinates is that correct no
so in in 2D you give two coordinates the
radial and the
um the extensional coordinate it's
basically a central record in the system
where you have the the angular
coordinates eliminated
I understand that but so a 3D system
turns into an effective two-coordinate
correct correct yes
um and what does that look like so I
understand so when when you where is
what is region symmetry an option two
of the silent mechanics PD component
so what happens if I put I mean
I see so so that's an axis symmetric
solid but I could as well have a sphere
in there as well as a cylinder and the
sphere would not be would just have a
different region symmetry specified is
that correct yes correct So within a
single modeling environment there could
be this is a description of the
component
not of the whole environment so to speak
so each of the components can have the
region symmetry
um
cylinders are different with different
where the generators are different you
know different directions right
I don't understand what you mean by that
well I mean the cylinders are not
oriented access to metric is for each
cylinder it's actually symmetric but in
the whole thing there could be multiple
cylinders there is that correct
the geometry can be arbitrary yes if
that's what you're asking so yeah right
but this acts asymmetric refers to a
single component
you have many components yes you can
have many components yes yeah okay
all right so what should I be looking at
here I mean the the so the next two
points is
um about our extensions of the
hyperelastic modules so we've added new
hyperelastic material modules to uh do
various
um simulations
for
um different
models than what we had before so
there's a whole slew of hyper elastic
models you open that other section below
there Stephen you'll see there's a whole
um whole world of them what which one
which potential material models yes yes
okay
so these are all hyperelastic material
models and we're starting to implement
them
so we talked about this once before the
the analog of um a viscosity for solids
and stuff like this is that yeah correct
yeah
so what we Cur what we until what for
version 13.1 what we could do is near
hook and Sandman a user-defined model
and now we've added another model Yahoo
model
and we've implemented the infrastructure
to add more of these hyperelastic
material models
is this something where we should be
eventually planning a materials
repository that has all sorts of
properties and materials yeah it's it's
at least we should think about it
whether we should do it is a different
question but we should think about this
about this at some point in time correct
but so each of these material models is
specified by some Association is that
true yes
so I mean
how many elements are there in the
association
that depends on the model so uh um the
yield model otherwise
depend that much on it because otherwise
you can't make a framework for it
well yes I mean each material model just
has different different parameters
so they're they're modeling parameters
what's the API down to the level of pdes
so you say yes you you basically say
that you want a material law it goes to
you and then you specify the parameters
that this model has I understand that
I'm asking the lower level API the yo
thing you know going below yo how does
yo plug into the pde framework
or does it have to be hard-coded
no no no it's it's predefined so you you
you just it's not the question I'm
asking I'm asking when you implement the
yo model okay you if you were to
implement one yes okay yeah right what
would you have to do then you say user
model or a user function goes to
whatever your code is you can do either
way either call them so each one of
these
is how much stuff is it like
well so lines of code lines of code is
about maybe 10 to 15 but the math behind
them is complicated
okay and there isn't some like book
somewhere that just lists all of these
things yes but that's still still
complicated yes there are books that
have them
um and we we're taking these books and I
mean that's basically what I've been
saying that we've implemented the
infrastructure to understand how these
models work and that we can extend them
now
so also the monograph have been extended
to to explain the theory behind these
models how they work and how you can
extend them yourself
so other people who do pde solving do
they have all these models
yes not not all of them but some of them
yes
okay
yeah and how fast are these models
coming out like every month or something
or are they do they come out 50 years
ago some of them 50 years ago in this
and a few come out new there are a few
newer ones but they are really
specialized I mean I have one student in
the Czech Republic who just implemented
an anisotropic non-linear material log
just a few days back so they're using
Mathematica to to develop this new
material law and hook it into the system
themselves so they just need to write
the material law and can make
experiments with that based on the
framework that we've provided
okay
so what should I be concentrating on in
this in this I mean so this is so
basically I mean this release was
basically providing the access symmetric
stuff for for region uh Force um solid
mechanics blow writing the
infrastructure for hyperlastic material
models and then we've added new
application examples that's what we've
done for this release and now you're
looking at the heat transfer application
example of a contactless heat and an
anemometer
again this is the color map of these
things not a hundred percent but it's
it's better than the default that what
we have currently
because you know we're making this color
palette repository yeah
so yeah okay I'll who who's doing that
well Tim shuttlebauer is involved okay
I'll ask him yeah the main person okay I
thought maybe we can add one that's
really more specific to for the finite
element stuff yeah because because I
mean we have one for you know for
geography and for this and that and the
other that's good that's good yeah yeah
I mean I would have one more than just
final elements I would go down to heat
transfer
yeah sure sure you know all this stuff
um
so this is based off of a model that
someone at Harvard made they simulated
passive due condensers and the nice
thing about this is probably the most
complicated so Stephen this is to
collect water in dry arid regions yeah
okay so you you can use the geoposition
of a device and then get the actual
weather data to simulate how the device
in that area were to work on on based on
actual data
but this I have a question I mean in the
modern world of llms where you know we
can imagine code getting written
have we tried
you know specifying modeling in pure
natural language through like chat gbt
with our plugin
not for a model of this complexity no
I wonder what would happen and I wonder
whether there's a way of doing it in
pieces
um
I just think that there's a lot of code
here
I mean
by the way
it seems to me given that we have the
capability in this documentation it
might seem to be nice
if you would do this in
I'm not going to save this file but you
know
you know make it look like math
since we have that capability
you see what I'm saying yep
I mean it just seems like that
emphasizes
makes it yeah it's kind of nice actually
makes it look less like code and more
like math
I would do I would do the same thing all
over actually because I just think I
mean Roger do you do you disagree in any
way no
I mean you have to watch things like
that which probably don't want to be in
the Dominator but I think it's you know
having the squad and things here it all
just works so we should show it off okay
yeah good good
um
you know think I mean the main there
isn't that much new material now that's
why I scheduled this proposed half an
hour
uh there's a lot of build up for the
future here if you can see there below
yeah
don't put an e in schlanger
oh Michael actually insisted I put one
no we should not do that that's not
we've done what we've done for other
well I don't know we did it maybe we
should use an uh yeah that would be
perfect
in every American English you know book
children's wrist spelled without the e
please don't let's put the e in there
okay if if I'll remove it again no
problem but I'll Michael will Michael I
can I can you can handle him
um I just I mean you know just tell
Michael just go look it up on the web
and see how many times each each thing
occurs
that's a good idea let's see what Wiki
says
um
well not that you just look it up on the
web come on I can do this you can do
this I mean it's just like so they use
the uh okay
and both
what do we do for globular basis it's
also are you right we have any the 38
million for the thing without an e
and the 1.4 million with an E so I'm
sorry the E losers
most of the ones with the E are actually
us
um
okay
I mean
yeah these are really important I mean
are there other ones that are more
modern ones
um that we also want to do
with Einstein equations for example
not at the moment it's modern about that
it's 100 years old right that doesn't
sound modern
well it's modern compared to
electromagnetics which is 140 years old
but the electromagnetics is used
massively
yeah well in our you know customer base
is so Advanced on equations so have you
been tracking Jonathan's stuff on the
Einstein equations a little bit
you should try to engage there I mean he
has this gravitas system that seems to
be coming together we did a review did a
live streamed review you can you could
watch it
um maybe a few weeks ago yeah um yeah
were you there no I had uh concert
tickets at that night was a last minute
schedule and I couldn't uh give that
back okay
um well you should perhaps listen to it
okay yeah I did I did I did I did listen
at the recording
okay so I mean
we need to figure out how to link stuff
like that into the you know the pde
framework because the pde framework has
all of this nice stuff for setting up I
mean okay the Einstein equations are
particularly weird in terms of their
initial condition set up
but many of these other things are not
so weird by the way I mean I assume
you're going to be able to do for
quantum mechanics you're going to be
able to do scattering Theory which has
complicated boundary conditions in
Infinity
we'll see which which we started and we
have an initial initial setup but we we
haven't gone that far yet but okay so
look there are two categories in quantum
mechanics okay
three probably you know there's systems
of bounded extent
right okay which
um like solid state physics type thing
yes I mean what like like things like
you know things in traps where you have
yeah right yeah okay then even the
hydrogen atom is even for those by the
way Stephen uh yeah that the thing when
you're mixed in uh electromagnetics or
magnetics
makes it interesting
sure in practice Yeah
right but okay then you've got the
hydrogen atom which is an unbounded
region but most of the action is in a
small you know small region right and
then you have scattering
where you have plane waves coming in an
initial condition and then things are
going out and I think I mean I don't
know where we deal with
I'm not even sure what you know
potential scattering which is scattering
off the potential
and I'm not sure you know the boundary
conditions are more complicated
right because that you have a plane wave
coming in it scatters from something at
the origin let's say and then a plane
wave goes out
or multiple and I I you know actually
well actually there's a spherical wave
that goes off and it can be decomposed
into plane waves
um anyway I just you know okay yeah I
mean I've got some words now so we'll
we'll look at those get covered
fine
um
I think you know in solid state physics
you've also got periodic potentials
what's that
yes yes yeah
which is a periodically why not right
but have you handled periodic
stuff already yes yes to some degree yes
there might be we might need to to um
improve that a bit but um in principle
we have some functionality there yeah
okay I mean it's going to get
complicated when you have Crystal
graphic when that merges with lattice
data and crystallographic symmetries and
things
um
okay
and what is the plan for fluid mechanics
so I mean we want to do basic coverage
that means um at least laminar flow and
creep flow
um so Stokes equation type of things
then I'd like to be able to couple
um fluid mechanics with heat transfer
via for example the busineska
approximation that's that's certainly
important
um then hopefully we'll also do some
mass transport fluid mechanics and mass
transport and if time permits I really
like to do
um
turbulence modeling to some degree at
least some degree I think my feeling is
that turbulence modeling is the same
what like hyperelastic materials are to
solid mechanics in terms of what users
need to do to get their work done
most people
just use some Eddie viscosity or some
such other thing you're not going to do
actual modeling correct yes we can I
mean that we we will not do direct
numerical simulations that's that's
correct yes
although the the framework
would allow that to happen if you have
large enough Hardware it should work yes
right oh and one thing what I've already
done is non-Newtonian fluids so when you
have viscosity that's non-linear right
yeah what do you mean you've already
done those I've that's implemented
fluids
yes Newtonian and non-Newtonian fluids
yes for laminar flow yes
but so for example could I compute you
know six pi
ETA a b you know the the Stokes drag on
a sphere
I didn't quite catch the acoustically
catch what what did what do you want I
was just quoting the formula it's the
drag at low velocities on a sphere
yeah yeah you should be able to do that
really
how would I do it I mean I mean you
can't do it now it that it's it that's
that's code that's in that's on my
computer
so I would recommend we review that when
we get there in the fall okay but I
would recommend that as an example that
you just know you know you should be
able to compute if you have a sphere
falling through a fluid oh numbers so
just we had some Oliver has done
something really amazing this morning so
ways of upgrading
uh you know when you start to get you
know not super high but dramatically
higher Reynolds numbers than we could
solve for before by using uh
parametric and dissolve to iterate your
way up
so say you have a a low Reynolds number
you get a solution from the from the
fluid mechanic Silver and you use that
solution to iterate a slightly higher
Reynolds number uh of the same problem
and you continue way up until you get to
a uh the Reynolds number you want to it
doesn't work indefinitely but you can
you can gear up to a higher reinous
number than you can do in one step
that's probably I really want something
about some realization group equations
for the fluid dynamics or something
because I didn't I mean I can't
understand why that would possibly work
I mean
basically I mean the thing is basically
that the the the Newton solver needs um
needs a larger convergence radio radius
and with this you you slowly step into
that convergence radius radius I get it
I get it it's not it's not it's not a
physical problems
um I see purely because okay yeah but
but so what you should be able to do
good test case
you know drag on a sphere for low
Reynolds number it should be linear in
velocity then it should go to be more
like quadratic and velocity be nice to
see that
and you should be able to see
uh be interesting to see can you see the
Eddies forming behind the sphere yes
you think the answer is yes yes I'm sure
we looked at a bunch of editors this
morning what about uh Vortex streets
the common vertex read yes
so you can get that is the break off yes
so there is not the boundary condition
so you have an inflow and an outflow and
wall boundary conditions like if you
have a flow through a pipe I know what
what but so you can deal with the
outgoing exhaust so to speak yeah the
boundary conditions which go off to
Infinity with with the vortex streak
going off to Infinity yeah
cool
but let's let's wait until fall to when
I actually have some stuff to show okay
well I mean I'm gonna make the
discussion a bit more interesting but
it's good that I've got some some points
that you're interested in and then I can
can take right but I mean you have when
you increase the Reynolds number you'll
start getting knowledge you should start
getting nonlinear interactions between
the vortices and the vortex Street
yes and that's where things start to get
very complicated yes
and I and I doubt you'll be able to get
that far with them we'll see we'll see
I'll take you by your word and we'll um
we'll see what I can get
fair enough
um
okay well sounds good I mean so there
isn't much
uh
do you have a nice table
um
table for what yeah I look at the PD
models overview in the in the
documentation type PD models overview
and there you'll see all the models that
we have
pde models overview
yeah there you go
and there you'll find everything in one
place
so where's the solid mechanics so
structural mechanics solid mechanics and
um yeah so this is the this is the
monograph on solid mechanics are we
printing these as books working with
that planning we we're starting to work
on that
they'll be nice
this is also going to look even nicer
when we have this elegant code
formatting okay yeah
okay but where do I get the table of
yeah go back up go back
and now click on the solid mechanics PDS
and boundary conditions guide
yeah so the solid mechanics PD component
that's where you uh
yeah so in the details section you'll
find
um
the stuff that's there now
this isn't grammatical for isotropic
materials
or for anisotropic material okay thanks
boy
foreign
so just so I understand I mean
the sigma
these are stresses
also stresses they're the off diagonal
stresses the shear stresses
okay
and because this is symmetric it uses a
shorthand notation
because yeah
but if it wasn't symmetric
then you'll get the full stress tensor
okay which is the same as the stress
tensor in like well I'm maybe asking the
wrong people in general activity
yeah yes you're asking though at least
I'm the wrong person for that question
yeah I don't know
um
but so
you were telling me last time about I
mean which of these parameters is the
analog of viscosity for a solid
I mean
um or
um let me think
I mean there's in a solid right when you
wiggle it around yeah it can
you know
energy can be lost through heat yeah how
does that happen what's the parameter
that determines that
so that there's a thermal expansion
coefficient it's a material that's
different that's when you heat the
material up how much bigger it cuts yeah
I'm asking when you wiggle them to you
know you have this thing and it's made
of I don't know you know plastic for
example you keep twisting oh I see what
you're saying Okay
um
I don't know
that that includes that includes plastic
deformation you know so when you and we
we haven't done that yet that's a new
field I don't know what the answer to
that is yet
okay
um
fine all right well sounds good
I look forward to the physics things
which I might actually understand better
and um
I think it really will be worthwhile to
try and understand what
how much llamory
is able to set up these really ornate
you know because it's good at writing
certain kinds of code and it would be
nice to know whether it's capable of
writing the kind of code you need here
okay
um
all right Oliver maybe one of uh
uh you know maybe one of the intern
maybe one of those guys can try it
they are in the process of building
these things now they would
right
okay sounds good all right see you soon
and uh Roger I suspect you're in the
very next meeting very much a focus on
the live stream we will be in a another
meeting in just a couple minutes
okay bye now thanks